so it came out when I was 11 and I
sixteen so it came out when I was eleven
I didn't really know much about it cuz I
was just like okay it's medieval really
care that much but then uh
so only somebody oh it's so good so
great I was like okay whatever and when
I saw that first episode I was like damn
he's good my connection to Game of
Thrones is very new I took a long time
to get around to see it and I had this
idea for a movie I was like I would love
Peter Dinklage to be in this film and my
roommate was like well then you have to
watch Game of Thrones you just have to
see him do it I was like fine and I
watched it and sooner then sooner than
later I was on season seven yeah it was
amazing my connection of Game of Thrones
is basically I'm a premium cable junky
snob i HBO market is something HBO or
does something a series and I'll give it
a try and they the trailer was for it
was incredible I remembers Sopranos in
the 90s and ever since then you know III
watch anything on HBO and then I saw the
first episode and that was sucks and I'm
not even that I didn't even heard of the
books I'm not a fantasy or sci-fi or
anything kind of person but the
characters the execution it was just
another fantastic HBO show so I was
hooked right then
very much yeah yeah it doesn't matter
because it's so fun to watch but no at
this point you don't even realize that
it's a it's a whole world it's a planet
there's continents and languages and
religions that are all made up you don't
even realize because everything at the
beginning the White Walkers you don't
even know what that is you all you know
is that everyone doesn't believe that
it's real so all you know is that you
want to watch more I think for me having
seen it so recently and now watching it
again it seeing all the foreshadow
that's when I'm like oh that's what that
man do you know and so having seen it
yes it's very clear where it's gonna
like I'm like oh that's I totally see
where it's gonna go but for the for a
person who's seeing it for the first
time or just an average audience member
someone who doesn't like critique film
or whatever I could see why it could be
very confusing you know I think they
very very well show character in a way
that I don't think any other series does
you know you see all these just random
characters just put in this place they
actually make you care for each and
every single one of them to the point
where you want to see where each
person's art takes them and I think that
what makes it so genius is the fact that
they're able to take these characters
their flaws their strengths and kind of
weave them together in and out to create
tension yeah I know I noticed that as
you continue to watch the show you know
it gets better and better you know
tension Rises characters change and they
do that to the point where you know by
the seventh seventh season there's like
a I guess like drastically different you
know watching back like you said so much
for shadowing I'm just like wow you know
there's so much work put into it I
appreciate all of that you know that
they're going south and you know that
it's gonna have to do with the Kingdom
and the throne but you have no idea
what's coming
no I right no but they plant a lot of
really nice Easter eggs I think yeah
dragon eggs dragon eggs there we go
emotion you know one of my screenwriting
teachers he always told me that one of
the ways to create compassion and
sympathy for characters is a emotional
honesty you know so even though this is
an entirely different time period with
entirely different morals and traditions
they they have a really good way of
making us feel for character whether it
be somebody who's down there look
somebody who is in an oppressor stirred
tattoo you know somebody who's trying to
find strength you know I don't know if
I'm saying her name right Daenerys is a
name yeah yeah I mean just her character
you can just see they make it very
evident they like the intricacies of
each character you know and for that you
feel for them because not not because
you're in you're in their situation but
you understand where they're coming from
so it's not just you know people talking
the entire time technically speaking the
first scene you see three guys riding up
to this beats out going north of the
wall and you have one character who is a
chauvinistic kind of guy and then you
have this other character who is
essentially in this moment the conduit
for the audience and then this other
character who's doesn't say a lot but is
the older of the three and they do an
incredible job
technically creating a contrast between
the older one and then the arrogant one
now when the arrogant one dies that's
our first in five minutes our first like
relief right in five minutes they
crafted this our first sense of relief
and then you see the older of the three
died and now it's our first heartbreak
that quick that quick because they
created the contrast to that fast you
see one you hate and one you you feel
for and you know whose side you should
be on and then they wipe them both out
and you're like in two seconds yes and
ah so I think that's why they're rare
they're really good at creating
technically contrasting characters ones
that will fight the other
that really applies to the children to
every single one of the star children is
completely distinct from each other and
that's something that you that you mess
up when you first start writing and when
you do characters that are close to each
other they have a lot in common and all
these characters are incredibly distinct
and that inner conflict is also really
big Ned Stark that one great scene where
he's thinking about whether to take the
job of the hand of the king and catlins
they're discouraging them and nice to
Lou and his they're saying that was a
different time and I'd be great in a
conflict and the gravitas of the
characters is also incredible Jaime
Lannister and the King and Peter
Dinklage's character Tyrion the great
gravitas really distinct and a lot of
inner conflict so the characters are
just great like that and then think of
all the things that you don't see coming
there's a really brief scene of the
Hound in there talking with Tyrion and
you have no idea the incredible arc that
that character is gonna be going on and
seven years later he's gonna be one of
the most complex and interesting
characters I think in television history
but you know that you see and you say
that leading off of that you see when
when the King arrives into town and and
the family's standing there welcoming
the king you see if you see a shot of
the Hound riding and they cut to a shot
of Arya almost an admiration looking at
him right and then we know where that
goes right and there's all this tension
built up as the King approaches and he's
just like you got fat in my hair and
also in the feast you know such a
relatable moment there's a couple people
like hanging outside of the feast and
it's like it's like when you go home for
Thanksgiving it was like the uncle and
the cousin or outside smoking cigarettes
like I needed to get out of there for a
second and it's such a relatable it
finds a way to be relatable at the same
time completely fantasy but it's also
that's incredible character work that
they do because I think that's like the
really like the true genes of Game of
Thrones because you get this time period
where people were truly misogynistic and
just like hateful and everything and
you're able to add humanity to them to
the character exactly I remember I
particularly remember hearing when
certain characters died people were kind
of mad about that people were sad about
that and maybe think like okay you're
able to create
compassion for carriers that you know
are by some means flawed by some means
flawed in ways that we probably wouldn't
accept today but that's again that's the
magic of storytelling I think that they
did that almost perfectly cuts the head
off of a little boy that he's never met
before and you still feel sympathy yeah
right that's tough
right right
they're very high concept very much very
I mean you can see all the symbolisms
and everything that's with it was in the
show from you know from the first
episode and you know since they have
seven seasons currently they expound
upon it each and every single time
there's there's so much work put into
this that we do see it's like this
moment a few folks you're like oh my god
I realize this you know so again I love
I love the fact that they do all that my
understanding a high concept is like The
Hangover something that's very simple
and instantly gets you to want to see it
so I maybe I've always been confused
about what icons that mean I don't think
this is high concept but I don't think
it has the burden of being high concept
because it's based on very popular books
so it already has an audience built in
it could be wrong about this but it's
not easy to explain to someone at all
you have to say it's one of those things
like you have to just watch it and you
have to watch it a while because you
could you could you could see the pilot
and also be like oh this seems confusing
I'm not really sure it's gonna be some
political intrigue show set in some
fantasy world but I don't know I think
my understanding a high concept is it's
really easy to pitch and and and convey
and explain and I don't think that that
that's what this is at all it's hard to
compare this to just about any other
show that so when we say high concept
can we talk about what we mean when we
say so that way we can have a little
more clarity I have understood high
concept to mean something you could
pitch in an elevator and I'm short
elevator ride or the other person
instantly knows what you're talking
about I say you know what I mean yeah
thinking high concept was like there's
dragons and and death and killing and
pillaging and magic and all this stuff
and so and and it's a very expensive
show to make high budget budget concert
right so yeah I never I never heard that
term high concept as far as like
something you can pitch quick using
pitch quick I believe it was was a nine
families five for the Iron Throne
I believe that's kind of the gist
of it yeah but even so if you told me
yeah to show about nine families
fighting for an Iron Throne that would
come true I would say what's on your
throne you know I mean fighting in the
medieval time sounds where you dope to
me yeah
how would you uh how would you are you
saying that high concept is based mostly
on how quickly you can pitch it because
good a good portion of films I'm sure I
mean pitching is subjective so I'm sure
the way I pitched on it will be
different in a way somebody else paid or
something but I think that would take
away its conceptual value would it again
I can coming back to the hangover as an
example because that's how this was
really explained to me when it where it
made sense if I said I'm writing a movie
about four guys celebrating a bachelor
party in Vegas they wake up the next day
and the groom is missing and there's a
tiger in the bathroom and a newborn baby
in the closet and I got to go find their
friends you'd be like oh okay and you
would you get oh that's what the movie
is about you can you can imagine it just
like that in a matter of minutes but
this I don't know I don't think it's
easy to explain to anyone even if even
if you said nine families going for an
Iron Throne
to be like what right uh-huh that's a
tough one I feel as though it's very
self-explanatory
and it's it's a in the way it's
portrayed you know then again I think
that is a subjective thing you know you
just told me how hangover sounded I
immediately thought it gonna be it was
like a super boring you know stoner film
look I love The Hangover I did but when
you had explained it like that I was
kind of like oh okay a series of events
happening but I feel as though we talk
about high-concept things I think of the
amount of creativity work and
originality put into a story you know
so while hangover is very creative I
think it also is high concept
I just don't put it - how quickly you
can pitch it because you know quite
frankly pitching is very subjective
across the entire board you know in a
pitch can I can make Star Wars sound
amazing but in the same sense I can make
it sound terrible just by the pitch so I
don't necessarily think that
my concept is based upon how quickly or
what you say when you pitch it
necessarily
I think it's an overrated concept anyway
you know high-concept it's not something
that you really need to think about
right just rights just write a
page-turning story yeah yeah thanks Emma
tea
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna lead off this
one okay being introduced to this this
world right we we automatically get a
sense of where we're and they have to do
this really fast because the shows huge
right so they have to hook us as fast as
they can and you know you see the gate
rise and you see this guy's eyes and
then you see his face and you see three
guys on horseback lead out to this dire
winter wilderness right and they're
they're showing cuts of the the land and
and we have no idea what they're doing
right and suddenly we see a bunch of
severed body parts in a very specific
formation and they blame it on a group
of people called the wildlings so now
we're cute in okay that so there's a
group we need to look out for and
there's a bunch of dead bodies now
that's not the hook the hook was when
they went back and the bodies were gone
yeah now that's where I'm like okay and
where do we go from here and suddenly we
see where these bodies are and come from
and then death occurs and that is when I
was like okay I'm in because things are
moving things are moving now so that was
that was that's what I felt I love
writing openings it's a favorite part of
the pilot its its natural habitat it's
you know before anything happens to
anyone you just get to show your
protagonist not in this case protagonist
but to show them a just a day in the
life as if there was just a camera
sitting there and this is really great
because you just don't know what's going
on there's so much mystery but you know
it's important because they showed it in
the opening and also when they show all
these enemies that look the Starks and
the Lannisters one thing they both have
in common is they both think the White
Walkers have been gone for thousands of
years so every single time their
reference to every single time you go
back to the wall beyond the wall or at
the Nights Watch there's all this
potential energy building that you know
is eventually gonna eventually going to
explode onto the scene
but no one thinks no one realizes that
these guys are back after thousands of
years there's monsters up there
everything else is very relatable it's
people it's politics everything
something on the wall and there's this
cold snowy world and those monsters are
back and they're eventually gonna come
and that's high potential energy being
just built up that you just oh my god
when are they gonna find out about these
monsters what's gonna what's gonna
happen when they do and also this
beautiful atmospheric for 60 seconds
they they utilized where they were
shooting and took full advantage of it
yeah and there's no talking and they get
all these beautiful tracking shots of
them walking through the woods with the
perfect gentle snowfall and you just
wonder if they cinematography audible
and what's so funny because like yeah
you know they they introduce the
wildlings like that and then and then we
are introduced to an even greater threat
in the first 10 minutes like you said
and then like you no idea where they're
going and then we're where we're at now
you know it's crazy yeah and then Stark
is the more that he knows everything
because they're extinct right they're
very good with the aesthetic I truly
felt the contrasting tones not not just
on the opening shot like from everywhere
from being in the forest the snowy
forest with the fog and everything you
could feel that they were in a daunting
setting you know when you see Daenerys I
keep saying her name wrong I feel like
but it has a very warm very warm and
inviting tone to it you know each each
and every single section has its own
vibe too and I feel like those pictures
are worth a thousand words you know
saying again they don't need much
dialogue I already already kind of
understood the context going in from the
first shot because you can feel it you
can feel it from the gate raising up you
can feel from all the shots that they
have and they took a lot of time to be
very meticulous with how they
communicate their story you know start
so many questions though the little girl
too is a huge part of that then she's
alive again and now you like I have so
many more questions to ask you than I
have answered it's just right like what
the hell are these things
there's no reference point now any other
movie or story there's no the White
Walkers aren't just like any other
there's no one to compare them to they
put your own level of the characters as
opposed to putting you in this sort of I
could say a high perspective omniscient
perspective does that make sense they
put you on the same level of the
characters as in you know just as much
as they do you know and you're as
terrified as they are because it's a
force that they'd never seen ilex it
we're more terrified more terrified
because we know something they don't
know things I supposed to happen yeah
yeah and it's because of that that in
just this first episode they set the
stage they ask us a million questions
and for each of those questions we want
to know the answer and they provide
stakes that if those questions aren't
answered bad things happen you know they
did that very well I think there's a
there's a great complacency they put
into the characters as well with the
white walkers you know it's like the
white walkers have been dead for
thousands of years like what do you were
you freaking out about like why why do
you care and we just saw them two
minutes ago and they're just like don't
sweat it guys and we are for them right
that's the thing about that title winter
is coming it's it's it's a looming
thought that they've set up that's
approaching slowly and as time
progresses along with the other
conflicts they set that up to where now
we know that that's coming so everything
that's happening also has this other
looming very dangerous threat that's
surrounding them essentially I guess us
it's always really meant to be the white
walkers are coming yeah that's yeah
that's right that's what that means
mm-hmm it's clever cuz we know what what
they're talking about like what he says
that is when Ned Stark says winter is
coming
he might be worried about snow but we
know what's really coming because we
just saw those monsters awesome open it
yeah that's the funny thing about that
is that even just that opening with just
those few scenes right there they set up
the entire series conflict that we feel
coming through every single episode you
know so that I think that was not all
that well done but they like it was very
strong a very strong enemy that didn't
feel like it was just
one force isolated if they like
something that was looming throughout
the entire series I think yeah for you I
think it's what's interesting about that
is two is is we get introduced them so
quickly and then throughout the rest of
the series we get very focused on on ser
seeing what she's her goals are and then
we get focused on on the wars and the
battles and they the white walkers are
always just sitting in the back of our
heads but we cannot forget about the
Vipers kiss you know the Serpent's kiss
or whatever we can so these they cloud
the writers cloud our judgment with with
all these on the nose issues political
issues that these characters are going
through and then we have constantly Jon
Snow coming back and saying we would
don't forget there's a bigger threat not
only saying that but they even if you
guys don't mind me putting this in I
believe it was season five or six
there's a particular moment where Jon
Snow was escaping from the White Walkers
and he had rose a whole like an entire
army up to fight them right and it was
the way it was like that shot alone dead
silent they were out in the snow and
just seeing the walkers come up and Jon
Snow just barely escaping through a
little canoe it was just like whoa so
this threat is getting closer and closer
not only that but they look to be more
powerful than ever
another thing by putting it in the cold
open but putting in the beginning like
that right before that incredible
opening title sequence the walkers for
four episodes right now yeah why the
moment you go back to that audience will
know alright this is important because
you put him in the very beginning you
had to put him in the beginning right
and then they went they would end the
seasons with the white Walker threat
approaching for the first couple and
then as the Dragons spoiler alert hatch
and they start and doing the seasons
showing the dragons but it's great
putting him in the opening scene like
it's just a little seed it's just a
don't let's just dunno let's wet your
whistle with this and then these
creative story arcs you know like they
made they made multiple story arcs
natives made the White Walkers one that
just transcends the entire series and
becomes a growing threat throughout the
entire time so under the radar radar but
it's like a rise
tenshun almost you know so that way that
when it's truly when like when things
get down to it it's it's much more
impactful the reaction is much more
visceral that way it is for me at least
when I was watching it because they
really they really made you feel as
though the White Walkers are a threat
that could destroy everything and I
think that's what I'm saying when when
you introduced the wildlings have never
done something like this we're
automatically ok so the wildlings are
bad guys and then a greater like they
put it they put a threat in our
interface and then seconds later a
greater threat on top of that you know I
mean yeah
mmm I'm not gonna lie to you guys it
took me I mean I loved the very first
episode but it took me a while because
at least to me I like when action ramps
up from the very beginning you know get
get me started let's see what's going
down you know so it took me a couple
episodes to get in but when you were in
there you were in there yeah it took me
some time it's just like a bag of tea
you just gotta let it steep and I was
not I was not into this flavor for a
while and I just had to I don't know why
I don't know why because the dialogues
fine the the cinematography is great I
don't need a ton of action but for some
reason it just it just took me time to
get there and by episode 4 or 5 of
season 1 was and I was like I think I
was really invested in in the characters
journeys I think at that point I think I
was because of you I got to know them I
got to know the characters in it it's a
big story with big big history and big
mythology and they have to take the time
to explain it to a lay audience and
maybe that's why but once I finally
understood the characters what they were
going for I was like ok I'm on board
with you you know in a two-hour film for
example you have to do that in the first
10 pages you know you got to get the
audience on board at this protagonist
and you have a little more time with a
series to do that and I think maybe
that's just why for me yeah I don't
remember exactly how many episodes
before I really was like okay this is
this is gonna be something really
special but I think but at a time they
got down at King's Landing and sort of
illuminated the rest of the board and
you got to see beerus a little finger
and yeah this whole nother location and
everything started to go sort of south
and you realize that jamie jamie and
we're gonna become really you know
significant rivals and they eventually
have a little confrontation and then you
know it kind of hits the fan after a
couple of episodes you know like whoa
yeah something really pretty bad is
going to happen these are pretty quick
I'm not gonna lie to you
when I first saw this like when I first
saw this my expectation was a little
different than it would actually would I
expected something like a lot I was a
big anime watcher so I expected people
would get like I don't know slashed and
have or something like that they do they
do and here's the thing when that
happened I was just crazy for it but I
expected like some crazy like
supernatural stuff to happen and it
didn't
but with what they have I think that
they really really like push the bar up
in terms of like TV show cinematography
set design all those elements I think
were done in a way that was just
cinematic each and every single episode
you know there was a big later on in the
first season there's a fight for Tyrians
life yeah in the Eyrie right right door
and that's one of the scenes in the show
that's like a moment when I realized
that like i was really in for a treat i
it's this it's i think maybe maybe
episode 3 or something but jamie is
talking to his dad for the first time
and you see his dad butchering a stag
and and the whole time he's talking
about taking over the kingdom
and he's filleting this stag and i was
like well if that's not foreshadow i
don't know what is and I was like okay I
think I think I'm good I think I'm good
yeah and he says good Charles dance I
mean I talk about talking about raava
ties yeah he says we could build a
dynasty that could last it that he says
dynasty yeah that could last a thousand
years or we could crumble it up nothing
and by then you hate the Lannisters yeah
like I want to watch to watch them
become nothing I want to watch them all
get killed
yeah he just despised the liners at that
point but that's another good point
right another incredible game play but
you believed them at that when he's
butchering this stag and he says that
you're like oh they're really gonna do
this there yeah they really can do this
and Jamie's like I could care less of
people think of me and Charles dances
like that and Tywin's like no that's
what you want people to think about
the writing has stolen crap yeah they
have a lot of attention this style and
character again I feel like this store
the duh this entire series is focused on
the character so everything that
everything that people do says something
about them and I think everything almost
forced out something else so if you pay
attention you can learn a lot about a
character just from what they say do you
guys think that some of the characters
are a bit on the nose
you